but first the doj the FBI they need your
help they simply want you to close your
eyes cover your ears and trust them
completely you know unquestionably
blindly as we speak they are attempting
to block the release of the affidavit
that is used that was used to Surge
president Trump's home uh they don't
want to you to know exactly why they
went in they don't want you to know uh
exactly why they went in and for the
first time in history they want to hide
the justification for their judge shop
Trump hating Obama loving not approved
by the Senate magistrate they just want
you to trust them now of course
Democrats the mob the media they're more
than happy to oblige in fact many
so-called journalists are eager to
publish information from government
sources Anonymous as they always are no
questions asked for example just
yesterday CBS News their top anchor noro
O'Donnell issued this tweet according to
a doj official the FBI is not in
possession of former president Trump's
passports Trump had accused the FBI of
stealing his three passports to expired
during the search of his home of
Mar-A-Lago in Palm Beach that was fake
news the FBI did in fact seize the
president's passports now Nora O'Donnell
got played by the federal government you
know you would think she'd want to get
the truth out there but anyway she
doesn't really seem to care as per usual
with the mainstream media mob and you
know like everyone else he's a you know
a liberal Democrat who probably hates
Donald Trump it's not hard to it's not
hard to spot these days and after all as
reason.com pointed out quote Democrats
they don't trust the police right
Democrats don't trust them they want to
defund dismantle no bail laws but what
now they trust the FBI providing that
they only target Donald Trump and by the
way they more than doubled the number of
IRS agents to harass all of you it's a
pretty amazing bill they say we're not
going to to raise taxes on people making
four hundred thousand dollars a year
that bill raises taxes on every American
because of the gas oil and cold tax and
then the business tax and then the small
business tax you'll be paying for all of
it so while they're breaking the promise
now they're promising that if you make
uh below 400 000 a year you're never
going to get an audit I'm not believing
that either just like I never believe
keep your doctor keep your plan and save
money now without a doubt in the past
six years targeting Donald Trump has
been a top priority for the FBI
especially the upper echelon now the
bureau vehemently denies any and all
accusations of political bias we all
know it's BS just so that we are clear
here on this program here's who they're
asking us to truck trust you want to
trust Peter strzok one of the highest
ranking officials in the department he
was the lead investigator on the
bureau's most sensitive high-level
political cases today he tweeted this
quote why does Trump have two passports
the Russian passport of course is kept
in a vault and only swapped out at Third
Country meets so it can't be that one is
that supposed to be funny is that like
Hillary saying what about the emails uh
it's pretty unhinged this tin foil hat
conspiracy and frankly the rank
arrogance of people like strzok and
Hillary Clinton you know using a lie in
a theory that he perpetrated on the
country a guy that was once tasked with
investigating Donald Trump and a guy
that lied about Russia collusion Peter
strzok was fired three years ago after
an investigation uncovered a trove of
anti-trump texts and emails including
some from 2016 involving a plot a
specific plot to stop Donald Trump ever
having a chance to win one from August
16th a text from his FBI girlfriend Lisa
Page reading Trump's not going to ever
become president right right and struck
responds quote no he's not we will stop
it that was on August 8th a week later
he texted quote I want to believe that
the path that you threw out for
consideration and Andy I assume Andy
McCabe's office that there's no way that
he gets elected but I'm afraid we can't
take that risk it's like an insurance
policy and the unlikely event you die
before 40. so we'll stop it and we have
an insurance policy uh wow talk about an
effort to smear Donald Trump and the
unlikely event that he actually is liked
by the American people will prevent him
from taking office now this brings us by
the way to Peter struck's former boss
that's former FBI deputy director Andy
McCabe who was fired from The Bureau for
lying and leaking McCabe has since
apologized for his behavior a little too
little too late but is now gainfully
employed at fake news CNN where he's
regularly trashing Donald Trump and
every other conservative and Republican
he can and then there's struck secret
girlfriend top FBI attorney Lisa Page
well she Departed the FBI and now
regularly trust is Trump as an employee
of NBC at msdnc and all told
10 former doj and FBI officials now work
for fake news CNN or msdnc these are the
two networks dedicated to smearing
slandering besmirching Donald Trump and
every other conservative in the country
but we're just supposed to believe
there's no political bias and believe
the FBI and believe the doj even after
the Russia hoax the alpha Bank hoax the
Hillary dirty dossier hoax the fisa
abuse Mueller's what two plus year Witch
Hunt the move to label angry parents at
school board meetings as domestic
terrorists the willingness to prosecute
not prosecute rioters from the summer of
2020 and many of those people lying to
us saying oh they're not really riots
they're mostly peaceful the ones that
are killing dozens of Americans hurting
thousands of cops and destroying
billions in property damage sure they're
mostly peaceful and let's not forget the
early morning raids on Paul manafort and
Roger Stone and now Donald Trump himself
now remind me how many Biden Associates
have been rated because of the blatant
crimes uncovered on Hunter Biden's hard
drive that the FBI has had for nearly
two years how many Clinton Associates
were thrown in shackles after she
mishandled top secret classified
information likely hacked by our enemies
foreign countries and obstructed Justice
how many Democrats have gone to jail
because of process crimes can you name a
single one again let me be clear I
respect FBI Rank and file special agents
who do the work at that protect and
serve all of this country they do the
right thing I have zero respect for the
upper echelon of the FBI and I certainly
don't trust any of them and they have
earned all of our distrust they leaked
they lie and they have turned America's
Premier law enforcement body into a wing
of the democratic party make no mistake
violence against any member of law
enforcement is unacceptable they try to
say any criticism well you must be
advocating violence no we're not just
the opposite any threats of any violence
towards any law enforcement must be
dealt with they must be protected and we
must do everything we can to find these
people and put them in jail where they
belong just like Merrick Garland ought
to be enforcing the law and he ought to
stop the doxing of Supreme Court
Justices and the protesting and the
harassment and intimidation in front of
their homes and by the way if you look
at oversight that begins in less than
three months with the midterm elections
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else